[Music]
so what we believe about the world can
be distorted by the long-term effects of
repeated misinformation or the
short-term effects of campaigns that
carelessly recklessly willfully or
differently distort the fact in the past
year both of these effects have had
significant impact around the world most
notably in the u.s. elections or in the
UK referendum it's been summed up as a
post truth world full of fake news and
whether or not whether or not the
problem
I covered my writings so it's been
summed up as opposed to two hours for
fake news and whether or not do you
think those terms are helpful
the problem is unmistakable people
distort facts and we all believe crap
about the world as a result so the
choice the citizens have is to discuss
everything that's one of them but we all
need information to place trust widely
and when you don't have that the
alternatives are pretty awful you have
the choice of blind faith trust
absolutely everything that you hear
blind cynicism distrust everything that
you hear or complete apathy just shut
off because what can you trust who can
you trust and once you have those
choices you leave it's a bit of a
dangerous situation to be in because
what you have is a Civic vacuum and
there are some that are happier to fill
that Civic vacuum than others so in the
past the pragmatic response was to
decide what sources of information do
trust
do you trust the Guardian do trust the
Daily Mail teacher has to be received
and even before that when there were
fewer sources it was easier to place
trust selectively but now there are so
many sources and actually we have
partners and sources talking directly to
people without any scrutiny in the
middle
Spidy worry
and on top of that you have modern
systems and platforms that allow for the
exploitation of information sharing but
without actually holding that to any
kind of standards the platforms are
starting to wake up to this problem
which in part was created by them I'm
not here to state them but their choices
of ad revenue models and the algorithm
choices have resulted in some of this
but like I said they are beginning to
wake up to this problem and actually
Facebook released a 13-page dossier on
how they're going to start working on
this and they've started to make some
product changes and they've started
Google have also started to highlight
fact checks and search and have created
a schema for fact-checking and are
starting to do some interesting things
in the space so I'd need them as I work
it for fact it's an independent
fact-checking organization and we've
been at the heart of all of these
questions and problems since 2010 before
I hand over to well who's director of
full facts I'd like to destroy the terms
make news for you because fake news is a
really awful term that doesn't help
anyone because the problem is much more
complicated than that it's not just one
it's being used as a catch-all to mean a
lot of different things so this is from
a blog post that I've just tweeted out
from the full fact account and it's
homework for all of you please go and
read it if I can do one thing a second
levy was one thing it please read that
blog post and stop using the term tech
news fake news the different types of it
can be broken down into one end of the
spectrum satire or parody things that
have false connections might be a
headline that doesn't match up with the
article it might be misleading content
in the ceiling use of information to
frame an issue or individual false
context imposter context manipulative
context or at the other end inspector a
totally fabricated context so these are
different types and then you get the
different reasons why this happens it
might be poor journalism it might be to
parody to provoke because they care
about it the very posh
might be partisanship it might be profit
it might be political sense or state-led
propaganda that's taken you and then on
top of that you also have different
distribution mechanisms whether it's
your aren't sharing something that's
wrong or both are me at the other ends
that are adding fake amplification onto
pieces of content so please go away and
read that and well will now tell you a
bit about what we do it for fact thank
you I'm going to allow some other people
to introduce our work before I start
always full full fact is an organization
which specializes in fact-checking
claims made by politicians and the media
so the panel a better watch out we've
had full factor independent analysts
call them project fact we went through
absolutely everything that was being
said how do we tell fact from fiction
well this man knows well moy is from
full fact and independent fact checking
organization organizations like full-fat
where they started offer a complete
culture shock to newsrooms across the
country because I think you probably
admit if you took quite a militant
attitude if we got something wrong we
would get a complaint and that complaint
would then go to the PCC as it was then
if yeah if it wasn't properly resolved
in the first gender so who are these
people why are they questioning it but
actually over the long run it's made us
all think a little bit harder than so we
can accurately gauge just how posh your
media consumption habits are by how many
of those people you recognize this is it
we have Dimbleby top left the famous
dimple bought presenter of BBC question
time Allegra Stratton national editor of
BBC News ITV News sorry Piers Morgan and
Susanna Reid who present on the ITV
breakfast show and Oliver writes the
policy editor of The Times at the other
extreme illustrating the different
aspects of our work the full facts
has been doing since 2010 we are the
UK's independent fact-checking charity
we are nonpartisan we are led by across
party boards we are running out of
technology we can trust thank goodness
we have been at the forefront of
tackling misinformation in British
public life since we began in 2010 and
that has included the AV referendum for
those of you who remember to re
referendum to go the Scottish referendum
and the EU referendum the 2015 general
election of the 2017 general general
election and the Leveson inquiry which
is part of what Oliver Wright was
referring to it's our job to back
journalists up in holding power to
account it's our job to recognize what
journalists have power to and help the
public scrutinize what we are all
hearing from politicians and journalists
and as meeven said more and more
directly from people without anyone in
the middle checking stuff for us and
that's a real challenge and it becomes a
bigger challenge when you get fake news
or perfectly useful terms that was
referring to cases where people were
literally making up stories on
completely made-up websites to get
clicks on the internet in order to make
advertising money that was what was
happening last year in the u.s. election
and then it became a term that senior
politicians in this country and in the
u.s. were using to trash journalists who
were trying to hold them to account for
the claims they were making and that's
why we have a problem with the term fake
news it's become almost a weaponized
term but makes it harder for the rest of
us to sort out what's going on what I'm
going to tell you about briefly is what
for thugs to help people suss out what's
going on and then hand back over to me
Vern who is our digital products manager
he's in charge of all of our work on
automated fact-checking
to actually show you some of how we're
deploying automation into our
environment so there's a famous
definition of a diplomat but some of you
may recognize a diplomat is somebody who
can tell you to go to hell and make you
look forward to the trip a fact-checker
is somebody who can tell you it's
complicated and they can not sound
patronizing a lot of people think that
our work is about bucketing things as
either black or white
true or false actually most of what we
do
is reinserting four shades of gray into
the oversimplified oversimplified public
debate that we all have to live with of
course politicians have to campaign in
bright language and clear distinctions
and we're all about to sit for about
thirty five more days of that thirty
three more days of that is it probably
but actually it's really important to
dig under those claims and understand
what is actually going on and that is
basically a simple process it starts
with monitoring what people are saying
having a balanced idea of what the
debate is out there spotting the claims
that are interesting important and
influential checking those claims so
that we can trace them back to primary
sources to authoritative sources find
out what those sources say and whether
they back up what is being claimed about
our lives and finally publishing and
putting that out to people so people can
make up their own minds about what to
trust and who to trust so let me take
you through some of the complexity of
that before we talk about what parts of
it can and cannot be automated because I
promise you it would have been very easy
to get somebody to come and do this talk
and explain exactly how fact-checking
will be automated
your life will be neatly categorized
into black and white by machine learning
and the whole problem will go away soon
anyone who does that is as most people
in this room will know a complete
charlatan that is not possible it's not
going to happen and until somebody
invents human-level AI that's not on the
table what we are arguing is that new
technology can make fact-checking
dramatically more effective but let's
start with what we can't do firstly how
do we do balance monitoring just give
you a bit of an insight into background
a full fact this is a poll that if
source Mori publishes every month they
ask people completely free response
question unprompted what do you think
are the most important issues facing
Britain today this was just released a
couple of days ago this is what we are
most bothered about as a country at the
moment EU NHS immigration the economy
that's kind of been a fairly consistent
top four for a little while now the EU
only became the most important issue
facing Britain today after the
referendum only managed to make the
number one spot after we voted to leave
and
the lowest point in 20 years of polling
for the EU in terms of issues facing
Britain see today was in September 2015
when only 1% of people thought it was
one of the top issues facing Britain
today so less than 12 months before we
all voted to leave the EU the vast
majority of people just learnt that
interested in the U which partly
explains why the referendum campaign was
such a challenging thing for both photos
and fact checkers when we were all
starting from such a low base of
knowledge and a low base of interest we
had a really difficult time last year so
monitoring balance monitoring fair
monitoring making sure that we're
spotting what's being seen and making
sure we're focusing on issues that
people actually think are important and
one us answers to then we have to spot
claims so here's a little challenge for
you this is inevitably a roomful of
fairly bright people this is something
we use in our recruitment process so
let's see how many of you could be a
fact-checker question number one the
claim record numbers of people are in
employment does that look sensible to
you could anyone see a problem of that
claim louder please
it's very vague can anyone be a bit more
specific about a problem with that claim
low or high population is increasing
thank you very much
record numbers of people are in
employment there are more people in this
country when there ever have been before
there have been more people in this
country than ever before for yonks and
yonks and yonks if you do the graph of
the number of people in employment it
has been at record levels for almost
every year since the 1990s since the
early 1990s vo sorry it's nice nice that
is the tech explanation of it it's a
vanity metric what you're really
interested in is the employment rate
what proportion of people in the country
are in employment and actually that did
hit a record level a couple of years ago
but after the government had been using
this boost for quite a while okay there
are 600,000 illegal immigrants in this
country what's the problem with that
claim by the way you sir come and see me
afterwards for a job 600,000 illegal
immigrants in the country
no reference point yep really important
point reference points remember those
words they're powerful anyone else big
round them very good point and of course
the really obvious question is did they
line up in a row to be counted
I mean how on earth do you know the
answer to that if you're going to make
such a bold claim about something which
by definition people are going to make
hard to count how are you so sure that's
the question we would want to know how
do you know that on average people spend
10 pounds a week on rail fares anyone
louder please point point estimate nice
but actually oh well done sir averages
can be so deceptive who are the people
are they commuters who by rail tickets
every day or are they all of us who
don't buy rail tickets every day because
actually if you account all of us you
drop the number massively but you give a
massively unrepresentative
idea of what most people who spend money
on rail tickets actually spend everyone
getting a hang of this so far this is
what we call the [ __ ] filter it's
the idea of you can look at how
something and have a healthy idea of
what question we should be asking about
it 22 million people watch the election
debates in 2010 there were 3 different
election debates if you add up for the
viewership of all of those debates then
you get 22 million assuming nobody
watched all three now that may seem like
a reasonable assumption to many of you
but I promise you I did all of my
colleagues did we were there some other
people probably did too
we're spending more than ever before on
floods of expenses spending over time is
completely screwed up by inflation your
Mars bar does not cost now what it did
when you were a kid neither do flood
defences cost now what they did three
years ago you cannot just compare the
raw numbers without factoring in
inflation and finally my favorite local
authorities in the UK spend 500 billion
pounds on street lighting anyone see the
problem with that over what period very
fair question anyone else also you're
already hired so you know
gentlemen are back their new street
lights or repaired street lights
completely reasonable gentlemen their
capital or ongoing expenses so
maintenance expects its out by a
thousand times it's a million pounds
just to give you an idea the total
public sector spending in this country
is about 700 billion pounds if we spent
5 out of every 7 pounds we spend on the
government spends on our behalf on
street lighting this could possibly be
true it cannot possibly be true that is
more than 4 times what we spend on the
NHS that got through a Daily Mail
reporter a Daily Mail sub-editor the
Daily Mail editor and into the paper and
nobody saw the billions were meant to be
millions mistakes happen
it's our job to help people avoid those
mistakes so checking things is hard you
need quite good instincts you need
actually quite a lot of background
knowledge you need quite a lot of
reference points you need quite a lot of
concepts that you can throw into this
mix and the more you throw them into the
mix the more we realize that actually
fact-checking is card and fact-checking
becomes harder when you turn it into an
NLP problem a natural language problem
of taking computers and asking them to
understand all of those nuances and all
of these complexities so let's take a
fairly simple claim like crime has
doubled in the past 10 years actually
that's a fairly reasonable claim you can
begin to see how a computer might get a
handle on that claim let's get the crime
data let's go back 10 years let's work
out whether now is 10 times 10 years ago
or find it fair enough right a more or
less what a presumably very intelligent
and bright researcher for the Liberal
Democrats did in preparing their
manifesto for the last general election
he went he got the crime figures over
their period in government and he said
crime has fallen by 10% over Lib Dem
period in government unfortunately there
are two different measures of crime in
this country you can either look at how
many crimes for police record which is
massively dependent on what the police
are doing with their time or you can
look at the crime survey which asks
people have you been a victim of crime
which is much more stable over time for
live demos on
fortunately chose the police report a
crime survey which you shouldn't use for
that kind of counting and particularly
unfortunately for them because actually
if they'd have used the right measure
crime had fallen by more than 20 percent
so they'd rather undersold their own
record in their own manifesto because
they weren't aware of what stats used
and when fact-checking is hard and the
more complicated the claims we make for
more complicated language the more
complicated the concepts things like the
Obama administration sense the recession
vagueness of the way we talk as human
beings all of these create challenges
for automating fact-checking
but here's another challenge this graph
really really simple okay this really is
simple right let's leave aside the
methodological complexity of running a
census and let's just say but basically
counting heads of how many people are in
the country right that's fairly simple
so on to me just one question
in the 19-teens which obviously is
around the first world war there is a
massive dip in the UK's population
around the time of second world war
there is no such dip - who I've already
not hired and gentleman over there has
also been offered a job who who I've not
already hired knows why there is a
difference between the First World War
and Second World War a gentleman front
page Spanish flu any advance on Spanish
flu I've got a Spanish flu here Spanish
flu here any rival Spanish flu gentlemen
back gentleman back louder please
damn I hate going to these kinds of
places
it usually takes the least five guesses
yeah so statisticians defined the
population of the UK in the First World
War as excluding servicemen stationed
abroad and so when they came back when
they were demobilize out for the First
World War the population of the UK but
went back up to almost where it was
beforehand so what happened after the
First World War
obviously they change the rules in verb
in Second World War period what happened
after the First World War why do you
populate in full so much we've got
Spanish saloons and opening deaths right
any advance on Spanish flu now - sorry
changing government accounting so we've
decided what people are no longer people
anyone else changing the way you count a
change in the way you can yep yeah okay
that's a perfectly reasonable idea we
have to really observe so is your first
one by the way I'm coming to it we had
some really embarrassing adjustments in
our immigration measures in the late 90s
precisely because statistician how to do
that but not this time
gentleman over there Sagan was it colony
sort of yeah this is when the Irish Free
State left for United Kingdom this is
not the same country at the beginning of
the graph as the end of a graph this is
a set of figures but looks so
straightforward you would look at and
rely on you will have seen people say
this is what happens adjusted for
population over time ask yourself
whether they knew that and whether they
got it right
fact-checking is hard because you have
to know your sources you have to know
your questions you have to know what the
data can and cannot do and then you have
to know whether there is data or not so
we spent two weeks in the EU referendum
trying to answer a very simple question
of where how many companies in the UK
exported to the rest of the EU you would
think hey this is a simple question and
B somebody would have thought to answer
it before we held a referendum on our
membership of the easy right we ended up
talking to the Office for National
Statistics Department of Business and to
other government departments HMRC and
somebody else about whether they have
any figures on this none of them did
there ended up being three different
data sets it took us three weeks two
weeks to get that much information out
of people we only did it by ringing up a
head of profession in the government
department and telling them to get a
grip politely that is the kind of work
of fact-checking delves it is
painstaking it is often painful it is
done on your behalf to make sure that
you have information you can rely on
whether people are making mistakes or
misrepresenting things it's our job to
help anchor public debate to reality and
that's what we're gearing up to do in
this election and the course of the last
two weeks we have slept very little but
work to double our team bring in lots of
extra people both working on from
location site and working on the
research side we're taking in second
deeds from the House of Commons library
the nonpartisan people who do research
their MPs in this country and from the
office for national statistics coming
into our team bringing their expertise
into our work we're bringing in people
to help us communicate more effectively
and digital and we're bringing in people
who can help us get our message out in
the media as well all of this is tiring
really really tiring and really quite
expensive we'll be mentioning this again
later but we are running a crowd funder
right now we really need your support
900 people are already making this
possible you could be the next hundred
people we could get to a thousands a day
that would be amazing that would make
this work possible so I just want to
leave you with this thought and hand
over to me them to answer this question
actually much of what we do is
mechanical yes you need the brilliant
researchers who will trace things around
half a dozen government departments when
everyone else has given up who will ask
the question where the press office
replies well nobody else has asked that
but actually a lot of the time is
politicians making the same claim we've
already seen that we need to respond to
you quickly
we've all heard our party leaders repeat
themselves endlessly we'd have to tackle
that problem and a lot of the time it's
just a variation on acclaim with figures
we'd be seen before entering how's this
inspiring idea for the Industrial
Revolution freed us from physical
drudgery a I can free us from repetitive
mental drudgery
I am the repetitive mental Drudge meeven
is the Liberator and she'll Nell tell
you a bit about how you're going to
liberate our team very time deliver
whelming ok so there's no way that we're
going to be able to replace our fact
checkers anytime soon
so therefore what can we do now because
we have we are 12 people and we are
bombarded with information and claims
day-in day-out and things are spreading
faster than ever before
and fact-checking isn't keeping up so
that's that was a big question we asked
ourselves one of the things that we can
build now and how can we free up our
fact checkers to work on the more
complicated claims like is the NHS in
process versus what is the population of
the UK
and we're not waiting for the amazing
advancements in research we're not
waiting for the neural nets to be
trained or speech-to-text to be a
hundred inaccurate we want to put tools
in the hands of fact checkers at the end
of the year actually now due to the
staff election in a couple of weeks so
we are building an automated
fact-checking
engine it does two things it sounds
really scary but it's not it does two
things it spots claims that we've
already checked in new places and when
you're sitting on 5,000 claims and
politicians repeat themselves all the
time and you have a pretty good
cross-section of all the political codes
in the country that's quite powerful all
by itself
the second thing it does is it detects
new claims automatically and status is a
data to fact check it we are very lucky
to live in a data rich country we work
with fact checkers in Argentina and
across Africa who do not have the same
resources that we have so because of the
work with the OMS and because of the
fact that they are pushing forward with
their API and making a far more nuanced
we can start to do things like this so
the things that it actually does really
simply is does the monitoring the
spotting and with the second mode the
checking so it monitors Hansard
everything that is said in Parliament
currently they're on recess or there
will be yep so they're not saying
anything anymore but we do have
everything they've ever said and that's
a pretty good precursor to figure out
what they might say we are also
monitoring newspapers so what are the
cross section of online newspapers
tearing across the country we're also
working on TV subtitles so at the moment
we're monitoring BBC one BBC two BBC
News and we're hoping to extend that for
the election to all the other
broadcasters broadcast is actually
really important because that's how
people get their information 66% of
people get their news from TV and we
like to think that the Internet is
actually how everyone gets the news but
really if you're talking about the cross
section of the country it's the ballgame
is still TV cool on top of this engine
what are we building the two fun things
we're building something called trends
and something called life trends is a
monitoring tool and it allows us to see
who is repeating known misinformation we
are quite unique as fact-checkers
because we do more than just fact check
we also get Corrections so we're the
reason actually that the daily mail and
son have Corrections columns you can
thank us later
çb our colleague works on figuring out
who are the people who are repeating
pieces of known information and she
spends a lot of time going back and
forth trying to get crushed and
depressed the first Corrections request
took how many months nine nine months
now we've got that down to hours or days
and actually during the year a friend in
those 2010 for the 2010 general election
we managed to get a correction in
Newsnight in the same program that was
amazing at the beginning of the show
they said something totally wrong we
treated them we got in touch to the
editor and at the end of the show they
corrected themselves in 2015 sorry yeah
so that's project so that's the point of
trends is to be able to target that work
more effectively and to figure out if
our interventions are actually working
is going actually you should tell the
story about Frederick Forsyth or maybe I
should talk about trends first I should
show a trend this is a shitty mock-up
that we did of what it might look like
this is this is for a funding
application where they want to see what
like exciting thing you might be
building it doesn't look like this
anymore but basically imagine a claim
that we have already fact checked
there's a study 8 billion pound black
hole in the defense budget and the
conclusion is it's an unsubstantiated
claim we have no idea where the
information comes from and then you have
all of the sightings the most recent
sightings and you get to aggregate the
information over time and if you
intervene at this point or this point or
whatever and you can see in a known
decrease you can actually see that you
have some had an effect in the world
that's really valuable for us because at
the moment it's really vague we don't
really know it
kind of a nebulous like talking to the
world is very nebulous there aren't many
metrics when it comes to fact-checking
so the Frederic full-sized story which
I've just ruined the punch line for
[Laughter]
targeting is that we this was one of the
first claims we put into our first
prototype of this system and it's been
acclaimed as bug dust for a long time
because MPs and the National Audit
Office and we and lots of other people
have asked the government to justify it
and they never ever gave us a good
reason why it should be thought to be
true so then we put it into trends and
we found out that half the people making
this claim were Frederick Forsyth and so
actually it's completely unsubstantiated
and now we know how stop it let's take
Frederick Forsyth out for a really good
lunch and persuasion but there is no
known basis for this claim and we can
cut the spread of it in half that's a
much much more powerful thing than just
finding one instance of a claim and
tackling one instance of the time and
that's the that's how much it will scale
up our work and that's how much it will
make our work more efficient could you
get up what trends look like now yeah
make your computer work without the fan
exploding yeah that's not best online
this is ahead for google book yeah go
ahead
okay this is that so Google an hour
featuring fact checks in search which is
a very recent development which is quite
cool so if you look for a cost to 20 a
day that's wrong it should be two
hundred thirty thousand but this was
done in a hurry to change it to Train a
doctor it will say fullbacks have an
article on that this is the claim this
is who is claimed by in his a fact check
so if you then click on that fact check
it will take you to the fact check that
we have written on that piece if we're
lucky
yep there's a crowd funder on the slide
if you want to donate so because I'm
logged in and it's not public yet there
is a small button and if you click that
it will take you to a page of what
trends looks like at the moment
if we're lucky so we have all these
claims and conclusions that we have
already fact-checked
I can tell you that we've seen this
claim 142 times since an unknown time
and because we're actually our tech team
is basically will and Jenna who's
sitting over there
and Skelly who has joined us this week
we haven't really got the resources to
be building incredible robust things
that look incredibly pretty the stuff
that we've been working on is just proof
of concept more than anything there was
like a lot of funding applications to
hire some developers eventually but you
can see last year drow about junior
doctors really clearly lost awesome that
was the route people were having and you
can really see that claim spiking at
that time she begin to get a glimpse of
why this stuff can be important for us
and then you get to see the sightings of
that claim below there's quite a few
from the Daily Mail there's some from
The Scotsman but just the guardian of
time but actually this stuff is also at
the moment bringing up false positives
matching isn't very accurate right now
there is a lot of low-hanging fruit in
order to improve that the matching is
being done by solar at the moment which
needs a lot more customizing so that's
that's kind of trends if I missed
anything else nope okay the other tool
is far more exciting this is primarily
for fact-checkers it's about us
targeting our own work of quantifying
our own impact in the world lies is the
other tool and it's the fact checkers
and journalist primarily for the time
being anyway it's a live fact-checking
tool we pioneered life fact-checking in
2010 what that means is that we take a
whole team usually a multi political
program or go to the studios of an
election debate and within seconds of
somebody making a claim we tweet a fact
check of it we are there to give people
the information they need to make sense
of what they just heard is it fair is it
true is it representative of as a wider
picture
so life has we started thinking the head
of news gathering at sky said it's
occurring with exact quote but he
basically said it was only possible to
do live fact-checking because we had
full facts with us Annie and Dale of the
LBC has also said I wish you were
sitting beside me every single time I
interviewed a politician so he started
thinking how could we actually make that
happen by the end of the EU referendum
and by the end of the general election
it was just like playing bingo we knew
what they were going to say I was like
whack-a-mole we knew where they were
going to say it was just about copying
the tweet and posting it at the right
time it was very little like research
that we had to do up front it was open
so it's all the number four that's all
my debate number three so we started
thinking about a tool that could in
real-time
take a transcript or subtitles and then
match against our database of claims in
real time and this is what it currently
looks like so it's not exciting let me
just refresh it
at the moment it is monitoring BBC News
BBC 132 and I'm just going to put it on
a TMP demo if it ever works okay get me
- basically it should this is a
transcript - something that happens of a
trees in May and Jeremy Corbyn talking
past each other at p.m. cues and the
subtitles at the bottom are coming up in
real time it is a demo but it if you
look abuse you using if she wasn't
coming up the real time and it will
actually match against our database so
that we don't need a experienced fact
checker to be working on something
reading mechanical we don't need them to
be looking up that fact check that we
did that while ago and posting the
conclusions we can get them working on
something like we are spending 1.3
billion for our foreign HS this year
yeah well help so I don't know if this
will be running fully but um as it pops
up basically every line that comes out
of the subtitles is broken up into
sentences run through a search system
install query search system called Louie
if it finds a match it pops up the
claiming conclusion and a one button
option - tweeter if we then take that to
the next level yes this is super useful
for us this is tools that we expect to
put in the hands of newsrooms and
journalists by the end of the year for
testing and working on the accuracy to
make that work it's the next big step
you can see already though but this will
change our election this will change our
ability to respond quickly and
effectively to politicians particularly
on air when you only have a few minutes
to get the right information to
journalists so they can respond let's
think about how that then jumps into
what we could offer the public and this
is the final thing we want to demo
dammit dammit dammit you have a URL us
all the time okay so under underneath
all of this is a few things going on the
monitoring and engine is Apache Solr
the store query engine during the
real-time searching is called a new act
developed by an open source search
company called flax all of it running on
hardware donated by bite-mark who are a
lovely hosting firm up in Yorkshire the
nerd hosting outfit of choice very
kindly donated back and supported our
work they are in the process of sticking
a TV antenna on their data center so we
can see these subtitles in we know get
it I mean dive into my emails and
grabber you're not logged in this or
that the other may be a knowledge into
the full fact accountants on thanks if
you're not going to see it that's
incredibly nice it's okay I will tweet
out and you guys will see Elvis so even
attended a Facebook hackathon a couple
of weeks ago and Facebook were super
excited to see this demo and she worked
with a team on Facebook life to
integrate that real-time sub that
real-time fact-checking API into
Facebook life so the demos that we would
like to be able to play you is of
somebody watching Prime Minister's
Questions Prime Minister and Jeremy
Corbyn arguing on Facebook in facebook
lives with real-time fact-checking
flashing up on top of that video in real
time so that no longer current
politicians kind of go out there and put
out flames that aren't backed up without
giving people context in real time
sticking all of this system together is
basically lots and lots of Python code
we're running into n LPS and Stanford
core NLP Python code gluing together the
monitoring engine the format in which we
load into solar and all of the external
products are running in Python or in
Django
we want to explain this platform
massively both in terms of what we can
monitor monitoring more online sources
monitoring more media sources we also
want to expand it in terms of accuracy
and in terms of automated fact-checking
so we have working code already for
assessing statistical claims
understanding what claims are being made
going back to your original data going
back to our database of caveats sticking
all that together and
dramatically reaching a verdict about
whether those claims are true or not all
of that again built-in placement I'm
using natural language processing
basically core NLP and pendency pausing
and that kind of toolkit if any of that
sounds interesting to you there are
three ways you can support our work the
first is by going to crowdfunded okay
dot uk'
slash full - box we really need your
help this is the most restful week of
our our of our week we are having a hell
of an election on no notice if you can
support our crowdfunding
that would be amazing the second thing
is come along and meet us this afternoon
we're hosting a hackathon cunningly in a
room with no plugs so please charge your
laptops in advance where we're hosting a
hackathon and you'll be able to get your
hands on some of this tech and work with
Skelly and Jenner and third row there
stick your hands up our lovely lovely
tech team to try and move some of the
stuff forward and bring it forward so
it's ready for this election so come and
get piled in there
the third thing is we are shortly hoping
to announce that we have funding to hire
some people to work on this project full
time if you think these tools are cool
and if you think these tools should be a
damn sight better and if you have
experience apply for an experienced
surgeon series of natural language
processing any subset of that then come
and talk to us and let us know that
you're interested because we are looking
for really great tech people who are
nice and who can communicate to join our
team and help turn fact-checking
into automated fact-checking and let our
fact checkers do more work better that I
think is all we have time for so thank
you very much if you have questions come
and grab us we would be very happy to
chat
[Applause]
[Music]